you woke up was it last week and you had
a bunch of ape coins what the hell is
apecoin and what is going on with this
this this whole thing it's like one of
the things people have been asking the
most about uh that i've seen on twitter
etc uh so i figured you could help
explain it because are you like a
apecoin whale now
i wouldn't call myself an apecoin whale
but uh you know i i did have uh four
board apes so i've been holding those
for a while and i had a few mutant apes
and some of these mutant dogs as well so
um
you know
yuga labs created apecoin and um i think
it was uh they distanced themselves from
the project a bit and launched it under
the apecoin dow
and uh i think that happened around
march 17th
uh the token launched uh at about 40
bucks then dropped to like eight bucks
and it's sitting between 13 and 14 right
now so the holders of ape
uh board apes uh received this ape coin
uh in their metamask wallets and uh it's
pretty significant to each board ape
that you own
uh you were entitled to ten thousand
coins and you know and how much was it
when it first when when the coins first
got uh air dropped how much were the
coins
well uh it initially spiked on some of
the uh on some of the trackers to 200
bucks but it pegged it 40 bucks
pegged 40 bucks so basically you so you
got what is that 400 000
for every ap you owned
okay
that's wild but some people got like a
million dollars if they sold it at the
top
that's correct yeah i mean this this
thing was uh
again when i when i did it
my my my bag was worth 8 million bucks
so anyway i didn't sell i didn't sell
because there was a lot of interesting
things here again i'm i'm i've dove deep
into play to earn strategies i i saw
some of the um the things that even uh
gemini if you guys do you know gemiini
has a credit card product yep
you can choose to earn your interest
payments when you use that credit card
and get paid an apecoin i'm not gonna do
that but that's interesting
it's interesting
um apecoin already has uh some built-in
uh functionality in the play to earn
environment there's a
company called uh
animoga brands it's backed by ubisoft um
and they've got a bunch of games coming
out that you can use a coin in and
there's uh selected merchandise that you
can only buy with eight coins so again
there's all of these different gimmicks
and and and
opportunities to uh to use a coin and
monetize it i'm not a you know i'm not
involved in the project i got some
apecoin for free and we're only talking
about it because you asked me yeah i
need i need
i need one of the pompliano brothers to
put on an hr hat whenever you and i talk
so that uh i can stay in uh in in in the
uh in the hr framework world you know i
want to make sure i'm there with your
dog yeah
as a fiduciary i'm i'm staying in bounds
i don't i don't do anything without uh
talking to hr
hr runs my life now
that's hr
yeah jason
those are my favorite hand movements now
you know you know those are
whose hand movements are those jason i
got a question for you
regarding are you gonna are you going to
are you going to stake any of your
apecoin
you know i i'm planning on just holding
it i'm going to hold it i'm not just
going to hold it and i'm going to watch
i'm going to watch and i'm going to hold
a coin so how much money did you lose
from the top down
in terms of
so it was that eight million and if it
comes down then it went from 200 to 40.
so basically
uh
yes you lost like a couple million bucks
in in
theoretical value of what it was worth
that you got for free
yeah yeah like look i'm not a loser
i look like
i you know i i and i wanted to come on
here and actually and say something very
important today
can't wait
yeah
i have not been a drake fan
and i've constantly kind of bagged on
drake and i
just wasn't into it but i never really
listened to drake all right so over the
last day
i've been listening to continuous drake
on uh on pandora and i have to say i
relate to most of his lyrics
and um i'm a big fan now like i'm
i am i am drake's muse
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time